seaweed is washing up all over the
beaches of southern Spain it's an
eyesore but it also threatens an ancient
way of life
Alma drama is a fishing technique dating
back more than 3,000 years nets are
positioned in sections of the sea close
to the Strait of Gibraltar to catch tuna
as they migrate from the Atlantic to the
Mediterranean in recent years fishermen
say their nets have been clogged up with
nothing but seaweed seaweed is
proliferating in this area as never
before I've been fishing for 35 years
and it's become a huge problem it's
causing great economic hardship and it's
endangering I'm a driver fishing attack
fishermen cast the nets in March and
pull them up in June they say the
invasive seaweed is scaring away the
fish it sticks to the net and then grows
creating an underwater wall the weight
and the tension breaks the Nets also
tuna is a fish that likes clear water so
when it sees darkness it swims away the
seaweed causing the problems originates
in Japan scientists have been studying
how it ended up in the waters around
Spain the seaweed may have come from the
Marseille area from a lagoon installed
in 2002 to facilitate the cultivation of
Japanese oysters ships probably carried
it from there to here all this coincided
with the highest temperature recorded in
the south of the Iberian Peninsula in
2015 so the stars aligned in this
species has increased dramatically
scientists are developing a coating that
could be applied to nets to stop seaweed
attaching to them for fishermen who
didn't catch their quota of tuna last
year and won't this year a solution
can't come soon enough
Victoria Gaytan B al-jazeera